في اخر التطورات الميدانيه وفي مقاطعه
زبوجيا قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قواتها دمرت ثلاثه مستودعات صواريخ وذخيره
للقوات الاخرانيه من جهتها قالت سلطات
زمولوجيا المواليه لروسيا ان قصفا
اوكرانيا استهدف صباح اليوم المنطقه
الصناعيه التابعه لمحطه زاباروجيا للطاقه
النوويه
اكدت السلطات المحليه تعرض احد مصانع
الكيماويات لقصف مدفعي اوكراني دون تسجيل
اصابات وبالانتقال الى البحر الاسود قالت
قياده العمليه الجنوبيه الاخرانيه ان
قواتها رصدت تحركات ل 15 سفينه روسيا
بينها حاملتين صواريخ في السياق نفسه قالت
قياده القوات الجويه الاخرانيه ان مناطق
كيف وخيرسون وزا بروجا وميكو لايف تعرضت
لقصف روسي بوابل من الصواريخ من البحر
الاسود وبحر قزوين